you see my form yeah okay so I just want
to see what you got
getting right here this room is the wind
it was wind there's the wind and then
like ten different things you do okay
okay so it's been a long hot summer for
me and I want to get back in the shape
of my life I want to be the king of the
court and there's only one man who can
teach me and that is five-time NBA
all-star Steph Curry and he's gonna show
me everything he knows
so let's not smoke bubble fans your man
Josh Denzel and we're here with Under
Armour and the main man the best shooter
in the game Steph Curry I didn't agree
man thank you
we want to find out listen what it takes
to be the best shooter in the game like
what was the kind of sacrifices you had
to make you know growing up as a kid
there's a lot of it I mean I can't say
how many hours I vlogged putting up
shots being in gym by myself with
trainers when teammates whatever is just
trying to hone your craft yeah well a
lot of what you see on the court right
now is years of just dedication to
getting the muscle memory right to have
that confidence in myself that no matter
what the situation is I'm ready for it
and obviously continue to get better
that's the drive that still in me right
now and no matter what I've accomplished
I feel like I can still get better
everyone's seen that tape of your dad
nailing that free point up right is that
some way you know when you shoot it's
not someone who you to talk to you were
like listen I want to shoot like him I
want to play like him it wasn't I wish
you differently so it's I watched it you
know what he did on the court and I
don't know if it's like osmosis you like
see what you what you want to do and it
kind of just happens yeah say if he
taught you how to shoot you took it on
can you teach me how to shoot oh for
sure got pass on the knowledge so I just
want to say what you got right here this
room there's the wind and then like ten
different things you did okay okay well
that's the one thing you did right you
held your follow-through okay just this
one thing you want to do is you want to
square up to the buffet so that's your
right handed right yeah yeah so I want
to have you right
but just in front of your left we're
obviously facing the best and from there
you got a little little a little
athletic position bend your knees the
only other thing I would tell you is
when you shoot and basically see it
right eye I want the ball right above
your right eye just to the side so you
don't block your view and then from
there yeah I mean there you're good
you're good though yeah then you just
got to practice and rep it in try to put
it right over that front of that basket
you're right there you get better every
shots getting better can I do one thing
you won't you what you want to do go up
to like you buy the shoot yeah all right
I'm gonna do a little something a little
bit emulation here okay
take this hand yeah bring it towards me
well here you go you got your feet got
your bounty knees all right we all want
you to do yeah yeah from here yeah
you're shooting at us with one hand
okay I'm going right into the bus yeah
okay you gotta learn from the best
I wanted to find out exactly what it
takes to become a pro because I'm the
best become a five-time NBA all-star the
main man the shooting King Steph Curry
it's been a pleasure
yes sir thank you very much your shirt
too
[Music]